[bones cracking]
Antonio Webb: I love those sounds,
but other people may
cringe when they hear them.
Hi, my name is Dr. Antonio Webb.
I am an orthopedic spine surgeon.
I've seen lots of injuries
in my 11 years of training
to become an orthopedic spine surgeon.
Been in Iraq as a combat medic.
In today's video,
we're gonna be going
over some movie scenes
and reacting to some of the injuries.
[Batman grunting]
Bane: Or your body!
[cracking]
Antonio: That's pretty
unlikely that that will happen
and cause a significant injury.
[Batman screaming]
Prisoner: There's a vertebra
protruding from your back.
Antonio: Their vertebrae is actually
sticking from their back.
That would be a pretty morbid injury.
But in this scene here,
the chiropractor that was trying to
push his vertebrae back in place,
that usually doesn't happen.
There's a new phenomenon
called the Y strap,
where they put you in traction
and they just pull on your spine,
[bones cracking]
but that's usually not what happens
when we're trying to push
a vertebrae back in place.
When we see a bone, especially a spine,
sticking out in someone's body,
that patient most likely will not survive.
The survival rating of this,
one out of 10,
just because the vertebrae
that the chiropractor
saw sticking out of his back.
[gunshots blasting]
[John grunting and crashing]
Antonio: That's a pretty hard fall.
I can't see how big of a fall that was,
but patients come in
after sustaining falls.
Usually we have patients that come in,
they fall from their roof,
or they're up on a building
doing construction,
and then they fall.
Usually they land, what's
called a FOOSH injury,
fall on outstretched hands,
when you're landing like this.
Usually they come in
with both of their wrists
that are usually broken.
Or they have calcaneus fractures,
which is the heel bone.
Sometimes when people land,
they landed on their feet,
their heels, and they
just crush those bones.
And they can have tibia fractures,
which is your lower leg.
We put them in what's
called external fixators
to stabilize that area of the bone
until the soft tissue kind of,
swelling goes down.
So, he would have most likely had injuries
to his facial bones, mandible fracture,
lots of different fractures
and musculoskeletal injuries.
Most likely rib fractures,
which are pretty common.
You can have what's called a pneumothorax.
The rib fracture will
actually puncture the lung,
requiring a chest tube,
which is a tube that is put in the chest
by general surgeons to reinflate the lung.
The areas that he landed
on, the tops of the roofs,
the things that he hit on the way down
may have braced him some,
but there's really no correct way to fall.
It's probably likely,
but he would have sustained
a lot of injuries.
A patient getting up and walking
after something like this is pretty low.
Jimmy: Holy shit, how much?
Vinny: Jimmy!
[crashing]
[car horn beeping]
Antonio: That's a pretty
serious motor vehicle collision,
is what we call it, MVC.
Some patients are actually
ejected from their vehicle.
This type of car accident,
where there's a head-on collision,
you can have injuries to your chest,
you can have injuries to your wrist,
to your aorta.
When there is a really fast
deceleration of a moving object,
it can actually tear your great vessels,
and these vessels can bleed really fast.
You can actually collect 2
liters, 3 liters of blood
inside your chest cavity
within minutes, within seconds.
And this is gonna be very fatal
for a lot of patients
who have these injuries.
Luckily, there's airbags
with the help of seat belts.
A lot of injuries can
be kind of mitigated,
but this is a pretty serious accident
where patients will come
in with multiple injuries,
polytrauma is what we call it.
This bone here is called
your C2 or your odontoid.
Can be a pretty serious injury,
especially in a young patient
where the bone does not heal.
And the option is to
put screws into there,
that bone there,
or to place them in a halo.
So, these are kind of
metal rods and clamps
that we use to place on the head,
and patients will actually wear this
for up to eight to 12 weeks.
And sometimes these
screws will become loose
or they become infected, and
they have to be replaced.
So, that's what he's doing.
This can be pretty painful
for a lot of patients
and uncomfortable, but
we usually anesthetize
or give them some pain medications before.
And then these bars and rods are used
to stabilize the spine, the head,
and then the neck until it heals.
So, this is pretty realistic.
But I think his survival chance
is pretty good at this point,
if he's getting a halo.
Probably six out of 10.
[intense music]
He did have a gush of blood
that came from somewhere.
I would imagine that it came from
his carotid artery, maybe.
You do have a vessel that's
on the inside of your neck, here,
that if you're stabbed or
that vessel was injured,
that vessel can bleed quite a bit.
And patients actually can die just from
if you don't hold pressure
kind of over that vessel,
but this is a pretty fatal injury.
Your spinal cord is actually surrounded
by lots of ligaments.
It's surrounded by the spinal column,
which is a number of different bones
that protect the spinal cord.
You actually can get stabbed
in the spinal cord itself
and sustain different,
various neurological injuries
depending on the location
of the stab wound in the spinal cord.
Is it in the ventral portion
of the spinal cord,
which is the front part?
Is it in the posterior aspect?
That will dictate what
neurologic presentation
that is seen, so.
The kidneys are in the back,
but a little bit lower, near the L1,
L2 region. That can be injured.
Your aorta is just off
to the side of the spine.
If you have a injury
or stab wound to that,
that can be pretty fatal.
You have to actually split the chest open
to actually find that
tear and try to repair it.
By that time, a lot of patients will die
from a injury like that.
But this is a pretty fatal injury,
that the chance of him surviving this
without attention is probably really low.
Two out of 10.
[bear growling]
[Hugh screaming]
And you can see he's
laying on the ground there.
This is a state of shock
that a lot of patients,
when they're undergoing certain types
of injuries or trauma,
your body goes into a state of shock
and you basically are kind of in a fog.
You really don't recall
kind of what's going on.
Your body is resorting
all of your blood supply,
all of your energy and your nutrients
to the muscles and the
body parts that need them
for that fight-or-flight
response that people talk about.
We do have other bones
and soft tissue skin
that protects us from outside injuries,
but you can imagine
200, 300 pounds that is
laying on a person or on top of a person,
that can essentially just crush you.
Your heart, your lungs, your kidneys,
these things are pretty fragile.
Dogs, cats, snakes.
These can cause a lot of injuries, also.
A lot of the infections that can be
in, like, a cat's mouth
when they use their claws
to get inside of a joint,
this can cause a lot of
damage inside the joint.
So as orthopedic surgeons,
we would normally take this patient
to the operating room to
wash out their wounds,
wash out their joints,
give them antibiotics, tetanus.
Most likely three out of 10.
[slo-mo cracking]
I like the extra added effect
that she landed right on
the barstool on her neck.
You know, there's a lot of
injuries that you can sustain
to your eye, to your facial structures.
You can actually receive what's
called a epidural hematoma,
and these are blood
collections, hematomas,
that collect either on top of the dura,
which is the kind of hard
structure surrounding the brain,
or under the dura.
It's called a subdural hematoma.
And this, when there's
a collection of blood,
can cause a lot of pressure on the brain
that, as you know, the
brain is responsible
for a lot of our functions, a
lot of our thinking, speech.
So, it can affect those things.
So, this is a injury that
can be pretty fatal.
There actually have been
lots of boxers who have died
from blows to their
heads, from these bleeds.
You do have some vessels in your neck
called your vertebral arteries
that can be injured.
You can have fractures in
your neck from that fall.
You may not hear the bone
fracture in your neck,
but the bigger, larger bones,
you'll hear that snap.
[celery snapping]
[bone snapping]
This scene is pretty realistic
in terms of the audio kind
of quality or the sounds.
We hear these sounds a lot,
especially in the ER,
when a patient comes in
and let's say they dislocated their hip.
Usually in car accidents,
when their knees hit the dashboard
and their hip dislocates,
it's usually called a
posterior hip dislocation.
In the ER,
what we do as orthopedic surgeons,
I will usually stand
on top of the patient,
on top of their bed,
and actually pull on their leg
while someone is pushing down.
And you can actually hear that hip
just pop back in the socket.
[popping]
Chiropractor: And relax for me.
Antonio: It's a very gratifying feeling
for orthopedic surgeons, especially me.
I love those sounds,
but other people may
cringe when they hear them.
I would say the survival rate in this
is eight out of 10, seven out of 10,
depending on what type of injuries,
what happens in her brain
to ensure that she doesn't
have any brain damage
or injuries in her brain
that could be deadly.
[web stretching]
[cracking]
The chance of someone
snapping their back like this
and surviving is pretty slim.
The major vessels in your body,
your aorta and your inferior vena cava,
these things are pretty fragile.
And when you take a lot of force
or when there's a lot of
force applied to the body,
it can rip these vessels pretty easily,
especially from a height like this.
When her body is snapped,
that can actually tear and
cause injury to the spinal cord
and the nerves that are
in the back as well.
I would imagine if she
would have survived,
she most likely would have been paralyzed
or would have sustained
substantial damage.
I'm a big Spider-Man fan.
I think a better kind of option,
he didn't have many choices at this point,
would be to cast a net
and she fall into the net,
where just this one web didn't actually
just pull on her spine and
pull on her body like that,
and she just forcefully went back
and kinda snapped her back.
This is a unsurvivable injury.
[car brakes screeching]
[crashing]
So, this is another kind of bad injury.
We call it a MVC rollover.
These are pretty serious injuries,
and sometimes they can be quite fatal.
He is rolling in the stretcher
through the hospital.
He most likely would
have a cervical collar,
which is a collar that is
applied by the EMS personnel
to stabilize the spine.
He should have had a cervical collar on.
They should have immobilized him
before they extricated him from the car.
The seat belts are important
as well as the airbag.
The airbag can actually cause injuries
where it can fracture your ribs,
but it does protect you
from the steering wheel
as well as being ejected from the vehicle.
So, you can have injuries to your thorax,
to your chest, to your abdomen.
So a lot of these patients
are receiving multiple imaging studies
such as a CT scan to search
for a lot of these injuries
when they come into the emergency room.
It looks like he had
injuries to bilateral wrist.
You can see the gauze
and the wrapping that he has on his wrist.
At that point, the chance of survival...
it looks like he's awake at this point.
His eye is, the right eye is open.
But the chance of survival,
six out of 10.
[Johnny yells]
[screaming]
How fast they were going from the sky
to actually have landed on the ground,
it looks like they slowed
it down quite a bit,
but I've been skydiving before.
I would have thought that the impact
on the ground would have been greater.
Usually patients, they
break their heel bone,
called your calcaneus.
And when this happens, it actually just
crushes the calcaneus,
crushes some other bones
that are in the feet.
Depending on the type of land,
whether they're landing on their feet,
whether they're landing on
their hands or their back,
that will dictate what type
of injuries are sustained.
The chance of them getting
up and walking is pretty low.
A lot of times we have adrenaline,
our fight-or-flight response is activated
and you have this adrenaline
after accidents or falls,
and you can still get up and do things,
but you may be seriously injured.
So, this was most likely
what happened in this scene here.
I would imagine kind of a
tuck-and-roll-type fall,
where you're protecting your
body and you're rolling,
and hopefully that will
minimize some of the damage
or injuries that you sustain.
This is a survivable injury
if it was based off of this movie scene,
but if it was in real life
and he had a greater impact on the ground,
the chance of survival would have been
six out of 10, maybe.
[car brakes screech]
[crashing]
Oh, wow, bowling ball
just comes out of nowhere.
Just hits him in the chest.
This can be a pretty
serious injury as well.
The injuries could be
anywhere from facial trauma
to lung bone injuries
to injuries to their soft
tissues, musculoskeletal.
That bowling ball probably
broke a couple ribs
when it hit him in the chest right there.
[cracking]
If someone did get hit in
the head with a bowling ball,
that's a pretty heavy ball.
That would have caused a lot of injury
to the face itself, to the brain.
There is really not much that kind of
surprises me at this point.
I had a patient come in
after a airplane crash.
He had a small airplane and he took it up,
and it crashed for some reason.
He had multiple fractures
and had a lot of other bad injuries,
but he was actually still talking to me
when I saw him in the emergency room.
We've had attacks by
different metal objects,
brooms, gunshot wounds, explosions.
I've seen it all.
I've seen a lot of bad injuries.
A gentleman who came in
who had leg amputations
from a motorcycle accident.
His body was on the stretcher,
and his legs, both legs were
in the bag in the corner.
So, that's a pretty typical day
in the trauma emergency room.
And as orthopedic surgeons, we
treat all of these patients.
Surviving a bowling
ball injury to the face
when it's going that fast is pretty slim.
The areas that he landed on,
the tops of the roofs,
the things that he hit on the way down
may have braced him some,
but there's really no correct way to fall.